>> Laura: AND SANCTUARY
POLITICIANS VERSUS THE RULE OF
LAW, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE" ."
WHEN IMMIGRATION CUTS WERE
ENFORCED THAT IT HAD JUST
WRAPPED A THREE-DAY SWEEP THAT
NETTED 150 ILLEGAL ALIENS,
MANY OF YOU WERE PROBABLY, BUT
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF WAS
NOT AMUSED.
LAST WEEKEND, MAYOR SCHAAF TOOK
THE EXTRAORDINARY STEP OF
SENDING OUT A PUBLIC NOTICE THAT
WARNED IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES OF THE IMPENDING I.C.E.
RAIDS.
>> I CONTINUE TO FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT WHAT I DID WAS THE RIGHT
THING AND IT WAS LEGAL.
I DID NOT GIVE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION THAT COULD HAVE
ENDANGERED LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I ENCOURAGED PEOPLE TO NOT PANIC
BUT TO KNOW THEIR RIGHTS, TO
KNOW THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES, AND
TO KNOW ABOUT THE UNIQUE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: NOW, ACCORDING TO
THAT WARPED VIEW, IMMIGRATION
LAWS ARE, AT THEIR CORE,
DISCRIMINATORY AND UNFAIR, AND
THEREFORE, IGNORING THEM OR
AVOIDING THEM IS NOT ONLY FINE,
IT IS THE HONORABLE THING TO DO.
SO GET THIS, IF YOU ARE A
CRIMINAL ALIEN, THERE IS NO
BETTER STATE TO LIVE IN THEN
GOOD OLD CALIFORNIA.
WHAT MAYOR SCHAAF DID WITH HER
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT EMERGENCY
BROADCAST BULLETIN, IT WASN'T
JUST OUTRAGEOUS, IT IS
POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL.
I.C.E. DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN SAID
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
REVIEWING THE POSSIBILITY OF
FILING FEDERAL CHARGES AGAINST
THE MAYOR, AND THE WASHINGTON
TIMES HEADLINE SAID, "LOCKED
LIBBY UP NOW, WORRY ABOUT
HILLARY LATER."
THAT WAS A FUN ONE.
HALF OF THE 150 ARRESTED WERE
CONVICTED CRIMINALS, AND THE
CHARGES INCLUDE GANG MEMBERSHIP,
WEAPONS, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, AND
DUIS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, SOME 864
CRIMINALS THAT I.C.E. WAS
SEEKING REMAIN AT LARGE IN THE
OAKLAND AND SAN FRANCISCO
REGIONS.
NOW, SOME OF THEM UNDOUBTEDLY
FLED THE AREA AFTER RECEIVING
THE WARNING BY MAYOR SCHAAF.
WELL, THIS INCENSED THE I.C.E.
DIRECTOR, TOM HOMAN, WHO SPOKE
WITH "FOX & FRIENDS."
>> AND POLITICIANS CHOOSE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR POLITICAL
AMBITIONS AND MAKE POLITICAL
STATEMENTS ON THE BACKS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT, IT'S TERRIBLE.
IT MAKES OUR JOB MORE DIFFICULT.
I WILL SAY THIS, A MAYOR AND
EVERY OTHER POLITICIAN THAT
WANTS TO VILIFY I.C.E., WE ARE
NOT GOING WAY.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP ENFORCING
THE LAW.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, THE MAYOR
DEFENDED HER ACTIONS, CALLING IT
HER DUTY AND MORAL OBLIGATION.
OH, PLEASE.
AND SHE LATER TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST," "I
CONSIDER MYSELF A LAW-ABIDING
CITIZEN.
I CONSIDER MYSELF A BELIEVER IN
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY THAT MOVES
TOWARDS A MORE JUST SOCIETY, AND
I DEFINITELY CONSIDER MYSELF
PART OF THE RESISTANCE.
AT LEAST SHE'S HONEST.
RESISTANCE TO COMMON SENSE, IT
MAY BE.
WELL DOING THIS, MAYOR SCHAAF'S
DANCING RIGHT ON THE EDGE OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE FOR
SHAMELESSLY PUTTING AGENTS,
POLICE, AND HER NEIGHBORS IN
NATE MY DANGER.
I REALLY HOPE THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
IS TAKING A SERIOUS LOOK AT
THIS.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
BECAUSE THE OAKLAND MAYOR PUT
POLITICS AND, FRANKLY, HER SHEER